I want to mention briefly something we
did on the show last week that got us
some attention we just happened to
notice at our program that during the
Super Bowl on Animal Planet hares the
Puppy Bowl for people who don't want to
watch football yeah so last week we
decided to offer the same service to
people who don't want to watch Conan
haha not funny anyway tonight it's back
by popular demand please welcome puppy
Conan
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[ __ ] cookie Kentucky's Andy are kind
of making our logo
I I know better than to do that puppy
amy has the audacity to drink love it's
unbelievable
puppy Conan can't believe his friend
would do that that's trying to get in
there and let's see I understand the end
oh.just nuzzling you Andy that's all I'm
doing I just wanted a little nuzzling we
also have added a puppy cameraman
tonight to catch on
[Applause]
[Music]
in those water compasses is that beef
gravy what I've been put in there by the
great he's not the gravies usually in my
cup I know
Oh Harry now he's got it the camp he's
got it now the cameraman has got it
they're eating the cup and the cameraman
is drinking out of that Cup and now it's
time to bring out puppy Conan's first
guest puppy flava flav let's get
[Applause]
play get flames clock off puppy Andy has
taken over the show
yeah plan all along
what does puppy Conan shooting right now
is he shooting anything interesting
no ok well that sucks there you go all
right we have a I love this set I swear
to god what I want to do is an entire
show on this set some night
[Applause]